[Music]
are electrons conscious
that's what supporters of so-called
pan-psychism believe
these individuals such as today's guest
philip gough
conjecture that you have to consider not
only sentient beings like you and me in
the consciousness project but you also
have to take into account the conscious
participation of the electrons in our
universe even those electrons that are
powering the very computer on which
you're watching this lovely video
i had such a delight talking to philip
about his many theories his
contributions what does he think about
his competitors or his collaborators in
the field of consciousness studies from
dan dennett to sam harris and annika
harris to those past guests on the show
such as david chalmers and donald
hoffman does reality exist without a
notion of what consciousness is
why did galileo exclude it from the
scientific process and what can be done
to rectify that these are the topics
that phil and i discussed you're really
gonna love this episode and i hope you
will uh subscribe and follow us on the
channel for more great consciousness
videos coming up as we explore the most
mystifying supercomputer that sits on
our shoulders our brain and other brains
and minds throughout the cosmos stay
tuned and come along into the impossible
with me and philip god
[Music]
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
well ladies and gentlemen
philosophers of all ages you're in for a
treat today
we were talking with the
really renowned uh thinker philosopher
author professor
uh philip gough who i've been trying to
get on unsuccessfully for over a year on
the podcast
and somehow after i made an appearance
on lex friedman and he made an
appearance on lex friedman the magic of
lex connected us right uh phil
oh it's great to be here brian i i had
no idea you've been trying to contact me
contact me for a year no i mean it
wasn't lex i think the first you can't i
saw you pop up on twitter dm
yeah they've been kind of trying to
contact me for you i'm sorry yeah well i
was using your website which has a
picture of a brain i thought you know uh
selfishly that's a brian or that's a
that's a plea it's it's it's a sign that
you should you should be uh receptive to
a missive for me and i i wrote you and
uh i think it was after you were on uh
michael shermer's show over almost like
two years ago yeah but anyway you're
here now we have an hour together we
have a ton of stuff to cover and you're
talking about my favorite scientist in
history and you're claiming that he made
an error and that's galileo galilei
and i wanna start off with before we do
my patented uh judging books by the
cover where you're gonna explain how you
got the title and the cover design for
the book um i wanna start with a quote
and i wanna know if you recognize this
and and if this was perhaps the impetus
for your uh ascertain assertion rather
that that galileo made an error a
blunder perhaps as big as as as could be
offered here it goes right is the
payback for this statement made by
galileo
okay what is observed by us in the third
place
is the nature of matter of the milky way
itself
which with the aid of the spyglass may
be observed so well that all the
disputes that for so many generations
have vexed philosophers are destroyed
by visible certainty and we are
liberated from those pesky philosophers
wordy arguments that was in a book a
known book called sidirius nuncius tell
me my friend phil did you write this
book to silly the reputation of a man
who who's sully the reputation of all
philosophers
no i mean i'm actually a huge fan of
galileo and you know it's a provocative
title but actually i think
he had things a lot more right about
about consciousness issues than we do
now in certain ways and
um
and you know actually i mean
one he was obviously a great
experimental philosopher using
telescopes to look at the stars for the
first time but actually i mean you see
he had him there appearing to have a go
philosophers but actually
one of the things i talk about in the
book i think galileo is
one of the few people to come up with a
philosophical argument that convinced
absolutely everybody namely his
refutation of aristotle's view that
people would believe for thousands of
years that uh heavier things fall faster
so you know you have this myth that um
galileo went to the top of the leaning
tara pisa and dropped two weights i
think historians think that probably
didn't happen
uh but actually arist and galileo rather
refuted aristotle uh not with
experiments but with a purely logical
argument and and so in a way you might
think not only is he uh
an opponent of philosophers he's perhaps
the greatest philosopher that ever lived
because of that argument but also
because in many ways the the philosophy
that lies behind the scientific
revolution you know we often forget
there's a philosophy a philosophical
picture a world view behind science and
that was largely crafted by galileo
himself yeah
yeah what's so striking and you go
through that story in such uh amazing
wonderful detail
in galileo's error we'll get into that
but what's always spoke loudest to me
about galileo is that he was a human
being and when you think about like he
destroyed the confirmation bias uh of of
aristotle as you just pointed out but
then later in in the dialogue which i've
just translated are not translated but
we've recorded the first ever audio book
by the time this interview with phil
comes out uh i recorded an audio book
with carlo revelli and frank wilcek and
fabiola giannatti and many others
and that's coming out the first ever
audiobook by galileo but in that book he
makes the case for the uh for the
heliocentric model of the universe and
he uses as a proof uh the sloshing of of
water as the earth rotates around and
and revolves on its axis and that's
totally wrong and and yet that the
underlying theory is right and i want to
ask you in other words he was right
about geo centrism being wrong or
heliocentrism being right but he used a
confirmation bias error he made an error
how is it possible that we can get
things right philosophically by thinking
purely philosophically um and yet be
wrong at the same time doesn't that kind
of call into question the ability of of
the human brain to to be trusted on any
level
yeah it's funny how these things work
out how great leaps forward can
sometimes end up being mistaken in the
the way they reached it even though
perhaps perhaps there was some
underlying intuition or some i mean
galileo's principle of relativity
perhaps some deep intuition galileo had
that
you'll know that physics better than me
so i shouldn't talk about things about
my pay grade but you know maybe even if
you didn't get the details right there
was something right about his
fundamental vision you know that the
copernican rep the copernican vision
underlying this and um
and the mathematical picture of physics
which is mainly what i focus on in my
book but you know i think i think we we
all need to remember that
we always think we're at the end of
history you know human beings always
think we're at the end of history and
you know before galileo people thought
you know aristotle had basically wrapped
everything up you know including that
the the earth was in the center of the
universe and and then you know as things
don't start to fit with the data
people try to plaster out rather than
looking
to rather than challenging those
fundamental assumptions people trying to
plaster over the cracks you know
postulating epicycles of the planets in
addition to their basic orbits and then
epicycles upon epicycles and then
you know eventually this is just swept
away by copernicus's idea and then
galileo following him and you know i
mean i sometimes think we're in a little
bit of that situation ourselves now with
with consciousness for example you know
we're just so convinced we're at the end
of history and our basic world view is
correct and when things like
consciousness don't quite fit in we you
know we try to postulate the epicycles
where maybe it's it's time to do what
galileo did which is you know think a
little bit further think to a kind of
new paradigm a new world view
right and uh you know this book is just
such a fascinating uh exploration of
both how we came to know what we know
about consciousness about um about what
we're going to get into pan psychism and
and also where we go in the future uh
but before we get into all the luscious
topics of this wonderful book i want to
first play with you the game i play with
all my authors who write books and it's
called judging books by their covers
yeah you're never supposed to uh you
know judge a book by its cover but i
learned if i've learned nothing from you
and my other philosopher guests like
peter bergassian and uh and craig
calendar here at ucsd uh it's that you
have to reason to the to the proper
inference uh yeah it's the only way that
you can judge a book if you don't know
anything is by its cover how did you
come up uh with the title first of all
and the cover cover design as well i
have to confess that both of the books
i've written i didn't come up with the
title for either the title of my i i
first wrote an academic book conscious
fundamental reality and david chalmers
came up with the title for that and then
um actually
uh nigel warburton came up with the
title for my book galileo's era which is
it's a kind of a similar themes but
aimed at a general audience trying not
to assume any under background
understanding so nigel ward robert is
kind of a a popular philosopher in the
uk
um one of the few philosophers who earns
his money just from doing for like
writing philosophy but not needing an
academic post very lucky for some but um
uh and he has the the well the wonderful
podcast the um the uh philosophy bites
very short philosophy uh you know 15
minute bites of philosophy which is
which i would highly recommend but
anyway he was someone who when i was
first starting to
to try and think about how can i
communicate this to a broader audience
because there's this huge idea that's
taken hold in in academic philosophy and
everyone's talking about it everyone's
publishing about it but nobody outside
of academic philosophy knows what the
hell it's all about and you know people
care about consciousness and
you know neuroscience and all sorts of
areas uh how can i get this idea out
there and he's someone who a couple of
people who really helped me understand
how to write more excessively and i
remember you know i i sent him a a
chapter and um
you know he said but this is just
this is just an academic book without
jargon you know you need stories you
need anecdotes you need and um you know
i was just talking about the galileo
stuff and he said
galileo's error and
i guess it might have been maybe in the
back of his mind there's a book uh
descartes error um yeah maybe there's
some connection there but i guess in a
way it's
in a way
maybe the title is
is it in a way i think probably what
galileo did
was the right decision because it sort
of put consciousness on one side for a
few centuries so that we could focus on
building mathematical physics so in a
way maybe it was it was the right
decision but
what i mean by it being galileo's error
is that
he designed physical science i believe
in such a way that it essentially
unnecessarily excluded consciousness
from the domain of science and i think
it we're now at a time in history where
we we need to maybe rethink that maybe
find a way of bringing consciousness
back into the story of science so that's
that's the that's the title the the the
uh the cover
uh
i think that the first few covers that
the publisher sent i
i really
thought were terrible
and it was uh it was someone you know
the designer i looked at i really liked
their other stuff but i just
and i talked to my editor and um uh my
editor for the for the book and i think
he just put it together himself actually
so we know we had the the publisher had
the design and make some covers and um
and
neither of us were happy with them i
think he said i'm glad you didn't like
it um but um maybe i'm giving away some
secrets here but it's
a wonderful designer i think maybe maybe
it was just not quite what we're looking
for and so i think the editor not a
professional designer just worked it out
himself and um i think the idea was you
know it's kind of an eye representing
consciousness i think it's made up of
fibers maybe representing particles in
some sense so yeah it looked like a
fiber like a particle track yeah
somebody asked if it's uh
on my youtube channel where i solicit
questions and
folks should uh
subscribe over there
dr brian keating i solicit uh questions
from the audience for all my guests
and one of them was why is the picture
you have here a grid circle that was one
of the questions so i guess we've
answered that now but let's go on to
what i
also don't like to do but but i feel
like we have to do because people won't
really understand uh what what is the
meaning of the title without a little
bit of of spoilage although it is the
first uh first chapter so they'll have
to get through uh you know the preface
and buy the book to understand i listen
to the book i love the audiobook the
reader
evokes your your wonderful delightful
mercurial
persona fella you'll be glad to know um
what is it scout leo's error what does
that even mean yeah the the the narrator
actually i think is is the star of
greece too incidentally oh wow
so carla revelli is no stranger to
galileo one of his books was narrated by
benedict cumberbatch and i just love
saying benedict cumberbatch but uh but
that's pretty cool you have a grease too
now that's amazing but yeah he did it he
did a really good job um
yes so that's i mean
as a bit of background i suppose
a key moment in the scientific
revolution is this
decision of galileo to make mathematics
the language of science and this is
something like we take for granted now i
think it's kind of obvious that almost
inevitable but actually this was a very
conscious and radical decision
um of galileo to do this and
um
you know
although this is much discussed we
actually
maybe ignore the philosophical work that
galileo had to do to get there as i say
he was not just a great experimental
scientist he was also a great
philosopher this was a time when these
things weren't necessarily so sharply
divided and that the trouble was
before galileo again you know following
aristotle people thought quite naturally
the world is
kind of filled with qualities if you
think about my batman cup here there's
the blueness and the yellowness out
there on the surface of the object or
you know the
heat the quality of heat as i touch it
smells taste sounds all these things
and i think for galileo the problem is
it's hard to see how you can capture
these
qualities in a in a purely quantitative
language like mathematics
um you know an equation can't pin down
that blueness that quality of blueness
if you've if there's someone who's blind
from birth
you can't give them some equations and
tell them
about the blue you know there's lots of
things you can pin down about the
mathematical structure of color
experience but
i think there's there's always going to
be the
the qualities that fill out that
structure maybe we could argue about
that so so galileo's way of getting
around this was to say well those
qualities they're not really out there
in the physical world
on the surfaces of cups they're in the
consciousness of the observer so for
galileo you know the blueness isn't
really there on the surface of the cup
it's in your consciousness as you look
it look at it or the you know the
age-old thing if
when the tree falls in the forest and
there's nobody there to hear it does it
make a sound
for galileo no observer no consciousness
no sound
so galileo sort of strips the physical
world of these colors sounds smells
tastes what's left when you do that
just
things like size shape location motion
properties quite conveniently you can
capture in mathematics so
so in this way
he allows us to mathematize nature but
he does that by taking consciousness and
its qualities out of the domain of
science and he saw them as not in part
of corporeal matter
part of the soul or the animated body he
thought that the body has a special kind
of animation
um this was an element actually of
aristotle he you he retained aristotle
had this idea of the soul as a sort of
the form of the body so the proper
domain of mathematical physics or what
he called natural philosophy
is um
what we can capture in mathematics size
shape location motion and we can do that
because we've taken out consciousness
and its qualities that's in the soul
that enables us to do that so the way
galileo designs science
makes it inevitable that consciousness
will be excluded from the domain of
science cut forward 400 years
galileo's conception of science has gone
so well and people are like oh my god
this is this is really working this is
the complete truth i think the irony is
it's gone so well precisely because it
was designed to exclude consciousness
seemed to me reading the book you know
with a physicist's hat on that it was
not unlike the situation with newton you
know constructing an absolute version of
time uh and in which you know events
play out as time progresses uh but time
is somehow uh absolute universal
uh and so forth is that was that kind of
uh you know influence of newton on
newton rather did that come from
galileo's perception of our
thoughts on consciousness or or
exclusion of it as you say to the you
know to being sort of the independent
variable that on upon which nothing can
be more primary than
yeah that's a really interesting and i
mean someone there is um people might be
interested there's this
collection of uh 19 essays
from scientists as well as philosophers
resp including carla revello you
mentioned responding to my book
galileo's era and one of the
contributors is lee smolen
who uh who think who who argues that it
kind of agrees with me that sort of
galileo took consciousness out but
thinks that the mathematical physics
that's resulted also leaves time out
real time obviously you have this you
know business of this mathematical
four-dimensional notion of time
but smolin thinks they leave out the
real dynamic passage of time
um
so i i don't know it's an interesting
historical question i mean the the
how newton uh
his conviction about absolute time and
its relationship to galileo i i might
guess my uneducated guess
would well non-expert guess would be
that
absolute time is perhaps the common
sense assumption you know it's more
something radically new that came along
with einstein um
relative time but maybe absolute time is
more the common sense assumption so
maybe it was something newton kind of
focused on and made explicit but maybe
it was just something
that that people
would naturally
would naturally assume so i mean i'm not
sure how much whether i agree with smol
and i would say you know i would say
the reality of
real quote-unquote dynamic time
i would i would say we have to be much
more agnostic about about that you know
i mean i'm
why maybe we're just maybe our ordinary
conception time is just wrong right
maybe we should
like i guess many people think
physics is dispensed with that um
i think i think matters are different
when it comes to consciousness though i
think that this is why consciousness is
so fascinating not only is it hard to
fit into our standard scientific picture
of things
it's also so hard to deny it exists you
know so this contrasts with say free
will you know a lot of people get the
idea that it's hard to get fit free will
into our standard scientific story and
this is a big debate but it's at least
an option to say maybe it doesn't exist
maybe we're not really free in the way
we think we are but when it comes to
consciousness
the idea that well nobody's ever felt
pain nobody's ever seen red
sound that just seems intolerable so
that's why it's such a fascinating issue
we can't deny its existence and yet it's
so hard to fit into our standard
scientific story of the universe
yeah you very tenderly and interestingly
point out you know these concepts of
emergence within physics and i wonder
you know to what extent uh we could talk
about consciousness without really
understanding emergence
and i think the
emergence here that i'm most interested
in is how do how do we unify
you know kind of this concept of of time
or can you decouple the concept of time
from the concept of consciousness are
they fundamentally intertwined and then
there are many who say time is emergent
and gravity's emerge everything is
emerging
and so i guess my my question
you know which which will now devolve
into a discussion about pan psychism
after you hopefully can give us a your
favorite definition of that um you know
we'll be well can we really understand
as i think philip morrison said you know
more is different more isn't you know
more in other words when you have a
collection of individual things they
behave differently than
end times those number of things so the
concrete question after this blathering
on is um can we understand consciousness
time gravity whatever um uh without a
real understanding of how
these things emerge um and and what
their fundamental quality is in other
words are we as i often accuse my
colleagues who are obsessed with
theories of everything i say why don't
you work on a grand unified theory first
you know before you tackle all four
forces just unify the first three
uh and you know don't put the the toe
before the gut i always say so are we
are we kind of doomed on a fool's errand
because we don't understand how
emergence really fundamentally works can
we understand consciousness with before
we understand emergence
that's a great question and you know
on everything other than consciousness
i'd be tempted to agree with you
you know how
we have a kind of
pre-theoretical understanding of what
time is of what freedom is of what a
person is
what
value is and then you might think um
well
why should we think those
pre-theoretical
ordinary everyday person conception of
those are correct you know like our
ordinary concept of solidity maybe is
like everything's filled in but
why think that's correct maybe it
doesn't correspond to the reality
i just think i think in the unique case
of consciousness things are a little bit
different and and that's because i think
at least
to some extent we know what
consciousness is before we do any
science um
you know so a lot of people say oh it's
a mystery we don't know what
consciousness is i mean
i i i don't like that way of putting it
i think you know in a way nothing is
more familiar than our
feelings and experiences that's all
we're talking about with consciousness
you know
pain pain what is pain it's um
pain is just a feeling and a feeling is
essentially defined by how it feels and
you know how it feels when you feel it
or think about a red experience when we
think about our red experiences
i always give that i need to think of
different examples but anyway think of
that you know that that deep red you
experience as you watch the setting sun
there's a quality a quality to that
experience that fills it out and i think
we we have some kind of rich
understanding of of
of what that is just in the sense that
we understand it's
it's qualitative character
um so we know something about what
consciousness is from the inside as it
were now don't get me wrong you know i
think we make all sorts of mistakes
about our consciousness uh the
philosopheric schwitz gable has done
some wonderful work pointing out the
errors we make about our consciousness
but
i want to say
there are things we know about it before
we do science
and
they can't be entirely wrong i want to
say maybe you disagree like
the way pain feels
um
i don't think science could ever say oh
actually no one's ever felt hurt no
one's ever felt hurting that hurting
quality that's a mistake or you know the
the ra the way redness looks the way
chocolate tastes
right scientists may be relative it may
be our experience maybe relative uh i
may see and call red something you know
that you call red but i may perceive it
in something that if i were in your
brain you would see as green and that's
all nagel thing by the way my my dream
someday maybe can help me uh phyllis to
write a book called what is it like to
be thomas nagle written by a bat
anton anyway maybe you could help me but
but that's not that whole kind of
perception as as uh almost a different
form of relativity but of course i agree
with you and and i wonder if you you
know consider this like have you ever
met somebody who truly acts as if they
don't believe they have free will i know
our friend sabina hassenfelder many
people believe in determinism super
determinism and she's going to be coming
back on the show for her new book coming
out later this year
but i want to ask you have you ever met
someone who acts like they don't have
free will i've never acted i've never
met someone i may have acted like it but
what does it mean that people say that
they believe that there's no free will
and then they act purely in concert with
the opposite of that of that conjecture
yeah that's a good i mean that's a
really good point i say it's an option
to deny the reality of free will in a
way that doesn't seem like an option
with
consciousness but but but can you really
have a choice but to deny that can you
can you really live that out i was
actually talking to um neuroscientist
michael ferguson from harvard who who uh
visited me here in durham recently we're
trying to make pun psychist connections
and he's talking about empirical work
actually where
people who do adopt a determinist
position and
which at least on an intellectual level
reject the reality free will uh have let
worse well-being so it can even if you
can't totally live it out just on an
intellectual level believing it uh
lowers your wellbeing i don't know
whether that's true
but i mean even though
he said
even in the uh consciousness case well
by
co-host of my podcast mind chat if i
could just quickly
is uh
is um
someone who says intellectually he does
not believe in consciousness at least in
the way i've just been characterizing it
so you know the gimmick is i think it's
everywhere he thinks it's nowhere but so
i mean
even on the consciousness case
there are people um daniel dennett in
certain moods who say
um
you know
it just it just does not exist but
you know to my mind
that that's a position
really is that the the at least the
position of least resort i think we want
to try and find ways of preserving
both the data of empirical science of
course
but also
the felt reality of our own experience
which which i'm inclined to think
actually is is the only thing
the thing we are most certain of you
know right i believe external world but
you know maybe i'm in the matrix maybe
i'm just dreaming but
the idea that my feelings and
experiences i'm not really feeling
anything i don't you know
so i think what i want to say is the
reality of consciousness as we
experience it is a fundamental
scientific datum in its own right and i
don't believe as a scientific community
we really treat it as such actually
no i don't think we do and then there's
all these canards uh you know we'll
typically
uh someone thinks they're really
sophisticated you know
professionals talk about you know
inference and reasoning and amateurs
talk about karl popper right so so the
canard you know people say well how do
you know you know that this that we live
in a matrix i had on david chalmer
chalmers last month for his new book uh
reality plus
um which is not sponsored by apple plus
unfortunately for him uh but it should
be it's a great book um and you know and
he goes through and he comes with some
probability and we came up with an
equation which i named after him the
chalmers equation which is like the
drake equation but for the probability
of the number of different sentient uh
consciousnesses in the universe at any
rate um you know he actually believes
you know with with some degree of high
degree of confidence that we are likely
simulated but he's not so dogmatic you
know david he's not gonna beat it down
your throat he's a star in your book
right um on the other hand you have
people that are quite confident um and
and and even in possession of some data
so now i'm thinking about uh stuart
hameroff and past guest roger penrose
uh and thinking about their their
contributions you know to to the study
where they have actual data from you
know their study of microtubules i
wonder if you could comment on these you
know relatively controversial figures i
know they're you know probably your
friends and colleagues in some sense but
but what do you think about chalmers you
know simulation if you had to give it a
grade um first of all would you do
is popper really relevant i always say
he even he didn't believe in
falsification as absolute but is popper
truly that relevant to the city of
consciousness we only have one mind of
our own at least so is pop does popper
play a role at all in the assessing the
likelihood and some bayesian sense of
veracity of claims that you make or your
colleagues make you mean papa's idea of
falsification or yeah the fact that we
can't falsify that we're not in the
matrix you know
yeah yeah well i i mean
i think as you say often i think we get
crude caricatures of proper you know
crude simplifications of the idea and
um but i i think i prefer to think more
in as you say bayesian terms rather than
it's you know it's impossible to totally
it's very hard to totally falsify
anything but i i would rather think in
bayesian terms like which hypotheses fit
best with the evidence it's very
difficult judgment call to make but it's
also a different question what what are
the starting points for theorizing you
know if if you're going to be a bayesian
you've got to have your evidence what is
our evidence i think a lot of people
assume
well it's it's it's our evidence is that
empirical
observation experiments
and that's definitely part of it but as
i say i i think that's not the full
story because this is this other source
of evidence we have
just from our our our immediate
awareness of our own feelings and
experiences so i think you know what
this calls for is a radical reassessment
of what we mean by what what the task of
science is i think people think the task
of science is
accounting for the data of public
observation experiments you know once
you've done that
job done we can go home
of course you know will we ever do but
but if you religiously followed that
you wouldn't postulate consciousness
because consciousness is not something
we discovered in a particle collider
it's not something we know from
experiments it's something we know from
our immediate awareness of it so this is
why you know daniel dennett is very
consistent he says you know
um
my consciousness consciousness in the
sense that philosophers talk about it is
is not a postulation of third person
empirical science so it doesn't exist
whereas i'd rather go the other way and
say no look there's this other
fundamental datum we need to account for
in addition to the data of public
observation experiment so that's why you
know
we need to think of the reality of
consciousness as hard data you know you
talk about pancychism or wacky theories
we say you know what's the data in
support of it well the reality of
consciousness is
a data point in its own right on the
simulation hypothesis uh yeah i
i chalmers said to me uh 25 percent
probability on our podcast exactly what
he said on the show too yeah well i i
it's a very interesting argument and you
know it should be it should be thought
about i i don't think i don't go for it
because
i don't think a simulation would be
conscious i mean that's a huge debate it
depends on what's called substrate
independence whether consciousness is
dependent just on kind of computational
organization where it's dependent on
stuff as a punctuation
right and a bit from it yeah
that is yeah and i often think you know
in terms of like extrapolating
artificial intelligence and you and lex
friedman talked about this and and you
and joe rogan talked about this web
links all those appearances in the show
notes and um but the
you know i i i wonder often that i've
said this i have my my einstein finger
puppet i can't find my my galileo finger
puppets in the shop i guess
but you know do you know what einstein
called his happiest thought of his life
uh phil
he's happiest thought i remember his
greatest blunder i'm not sure the
happiest thought no yes happiest thought
was that uh someone in free fall would
experience no gravitational force
yes i'm sure you do yeah yeah it's i
shouldn't have put you on there's a
relativity exactly which led to the
equivalence principle very good uh so
but i often think well like let's
examine an artificial einstein instead
of a e a i right okay so so uh how could
such an object or entity or being have a
sensation of happiness a
and then b how could such a sensation be
of falling weightlessness how could that
you know in other words we we kind of
impute today and i talked a little bit
with lex about that and in my chat with
him but but the point is you know how do
you imbue these things in other words
would we recognize it if these things
were conscious uh uh you know if we
could create artificial consciousness or
maybe maybe they or if there are other
conscious you know nest things are there
is it possible that there's sort of like
as paul davies says you know a shadow
biosphere could there be a shadow
consciousness that we just cannot access
because we don't have those proteins or
we don't have language or
is that a possibility um that's a kind
of the answer to the fermi paradox about
consciousness so to speak of why we
don't see other consciousnesses
yeah well as the thing i am most
passionate about conveying i hope people
have before probably get sick to death
and be saying this is that
the reason consciousness is can't be
totally treated in the normal scientific
way is that it's not publicly observable
now
scientists are used to postulating
things we can't observe
blockages
in this case the thing we are trying to
account for
can't be observed and i can't be
publicly observed i think that is
totally unique and that's why
i don't think you you can pin down a lot
experimentally about consciousness but i
don't think you could totally pin down
the theory of consciousness with
experiments because it's not a publicly
observable phenomenon there's always
going to need to be some kind of
inference to the best explanation yeah
and
i mean the the core i mean what what is
so excited academic philosophy about
this virtue and russell inspired pan
psychism that's kind of been
rediscovered um you talked about
emergence
a while ago is you know the standard way
of thinking about things is how do we
make sense of
consciousness emerging from matter
and we
get the hard problem of consciousness no
one's
ever you know despite our scientific
understanding of the brain no one's ever
sort of come up with a good explanation
of that a good way of accounting for how
consciousness emerges from matter that
what the pancikis does is turn the
explanation on its head right
instead of thinking how consciousness
emerges from matter let's think about
how matter emerges from consciousness
and russell's inside the reason we can
do that coming back again to galileo is
because
physics is purely mathematical
so
because physics is purely mathematic you
know physics just
identifies these fundamental
mathematical structures
so long as there's stuff
that
through its interactions
um
realizes those mathematical structures
then you can get physics so the pan
cyclist idea is well it could be
consciousness stuff we could have these
networks of simple conscious entities
behaving in simple predictable ways
because they've got very simple
experiences they they
through their interactions they realize
these mathematical structures
and that is what physics is studying you
don't know that when you're a physicist
because you're just interested in the
mathematical structure but that is what
you're studying so in this way
physics emerges from facts about
consciousness so so what we've got to do
is
thinking in terms of inference the best
explanation you know we know
consciousness goes along with brain
activity what's the best explanation
i i think the kind of materialist
explanations of getting kind of trying
to make sense of consciousness emerging
from mata i i it's a big argument i
don't think they work out i don't think
they've ever had any shown any fruit
there's this alternative explanation
maybe
physics
and matter emerges from underlying facts
about consciousness and i think actually
that's a much more straightforward
explanation so in in the sense of
inference the best explanation i think
this looks to be the best solution to
the hard problem of consciousness
let's get into this
that's gonna depend psychism in just a
second but uh first of all in the
audience we're speaking to uh professor
philip gough
of uh uh is it durham university or
university of durham
i'm not sure actually i think i think
you could say either okay either way uh
and uh the author of the phenomenal
galileo's error uh featured on lex
friedman's podcast joe rogan's podcast
and after you go on those two kind of
you know up and coming stars then you
come on to the end of the impossible
podcast uh he is also a podcast hope of
a host of his own uh and uh your podcast
is called mind chat and you can find
that wherever podcasts are sold and even
on youtube uh and so i want to turn back
to lastly to the to the before i turn it
over to my audience uh questions that
they've submitted uh via twitter to dr
brian keating and to philip underscore
golf
um and uh and on youtube at dr brian
keating on youtube
and that's uh another call back to our
friend galileo
who said the following he said the sun
with all those planets revolving around
it and dependent on it can still ripen a
bunch of grapes as if it had nothing
else in the universe to do
and i don't know if you've ever been to
galileo's uh a prison in uh in florence
but we hosted a conference on relativity
there in 2015 and it's it's a pretty
nice prison you know i think uh i think
uh delaine maxwell and others would love
to be there instead of where they are
right now uh but it has these you know
grapevines and olive trees and so forth
and it's a lovely lovely place but he
often thought amused about wine and he
said wine and sunlight held together by
by water um and i want to ask you can we
learn about consciousness from the
unconscious state uh
thinking about uh the anti-consciousness
is there something that we can learn you
know from sort of the counterfactual uh
as stuart hameroff has claimed he has
special you know kind of privileges uh
because he's an anesthesiologist and so
he can knock people out and i say i i
knock people out all the time just come
to one of my lectures
that's put in a drum roll right there uh
but but um can we learn about it from
from its opposite unconsciousness
absolutely yeah so i mean the way i
think about consciousness science
consciousness research is that it's
there's a theoretical aspect and a and a
an experimental aspect so the
experimental task is to try and pin down
what's called the neural correlates of
consciousness which kinds of brain
activity go along with which kinds of
experience and more generally which
kinds of brain activity are necessary
and sufficient for consciousness in
general
um
that's really important data but i i
think that always leaves open the the
more theoretical question why why why do
these two things go together and there i
think we're back to the inference to the
best explanation thing it's the first
time i've put it in in terms of
influence the best explanation i don't
when i was on joe rogan i don't think i
managed to convey to what the heart
proper consciousness was i was thinking
about
it's the host fault you know if you
can't bring out the best in your guest
you should think of another profession
maybe like you know epidemiology is what
joshua
just kidding joe i loved what you did i
was thinking afterwards maybe i should
have talked about inference the best
explanation that's a better way to put
it but um but yeah
in terms of the experimental task yeah
it's it's about
thinking of
trying to pin down as best we can and
it's very difficult where consciousness
is and where consciousness isn't you
might think it's a panzerkist isn't it
everywhere well
yes and no a pan cyclist thinks at the
fundamental level of reality maybe
particles or fields there's
consciousness but they don't necessarily
think at the macro level it's everywhere
they would tend to think that
the the the um the circumstances in
which
simple conscious entities combined to
form complex conscious entities are
maybe quite rare maybe
natural selection as it were discovered
this and exploited it
um so so you know pinning this down
you need you need to be guided by by the
uh by the science so science and
philosophy really needs to be work hand
in hand here and yeah a lot of it is
because it's not publicly observable we
have to do the best we can you can ask
people you can
the so-called no report paradigm you can
look for sort of external markers
and
make people unconscious you can look
where it's absent although it's even
that it's tricky you know do people
really have dreamless sleep or is it
just
experience
work that you don't remember you know a
waking experience is
connected up by memory second to second
whereas often when you're dreaming it's
not so much you can be suddenly
somewhere else and you don't notice so
maybe
so called dreamless sleep is just where
the
chains of memory collapse and you're
just having streams of experience
well not knowing from one moment to the
next so it is it's very very hard even
just with the experimental science i
don't know if it's true or not but um
a friend of the show kim stanley
robinson he wrote a wonderful book which
if you haven't read it's called
galileo's dream uh you would love it
because in the book galileo suffers from
these what they're called syncopes which
i think he did in real life
kind of fainting spells and kim uses
that our stan uses that as a vehicle uh
that really engages the uh the concept
of time travel and space travel i won't
ruin it although it occurs very early in
the book
uh where galileo during those moments of
epileptic seizure apparent to the
outside observer galileo's actually
being teleported to the future on the
moon europa
that he of course discovered
and uh and it goes back and forth using
this vehicle of these syncopes or
epileptic seizures perhaps um and uh of
unconscious to the external observer but
i wonder it would be really fun to have
you and and stan you know kind of gather
around and talk about these these issues
because um that that's obviously
fictional but um but but i think there
is something that we could say as this
problem of external observation and how
that may preclude you as sort of a
barrier that we have to tunnel through
to to gain greater clarity i wanna i i
can't i'd be remiss you know so like
when david chalmers on the show
i asked him you have to define the hard
problem of consciousness because it'll
be like you go to see someone in your
beloved country by the name of acdc and
they don't play back in black or they
don't play you know you shook me all
night long you feel kind of ripped off
so my audience will feel ripped off phil
if you don't explain pan psychism
pan psychism well
i mean
in our simple way of in our standard way
of thinking about things you know
consciousness exists only in the brains
of
highly evolved organisms and and so only
exist you know in a tiny part of the
universe and only in very
recent history and at least in terms of
the history of the universe but for the
pan cyclist consciousness pervades the
universe and is a fundamental feature of
it
uh so it sounds kind of wacky i mean i
suppose
i suppose the thought is you can think
of it as an alternative research program
right we've been trying banging our head
against the brick wall for many decades
now of trying to explain consciousness
in terms of utterly non-conscious
processes in the brain
um
i would argue that's i mean we've done a
lot that's good
understanding the brain and
consciousness but in terms of
explaining consciousness in terms of
patterns of neural firings i think you
know how the brain produces a kind of
inner world of colors sounds smells safe
i think we we've got nowhere with that
the pancychist
tries an alternative research program
rather than explain consciousness in
terms of the non-conscious we try to
explain very complicated forms of
consciousness in terms of simpler forms
of consciousness simpler forms of
consciousness which are then postulated
to exist as just fundamental
constituents of matter um so that's
that's the start of it and the russell
stuff i talked about earlier is it is an
important part of spelling that out in a
little bit more detail
now if we have a um concept in in
physics related to emergence uh but but
really it's mostly like linearity
i think about you know let's say there
is because you know the and i hope it's
okay to criticize you with with love or
connect not you but the theory yeah the
theory is oh pan psychism is
everything's conscious this rock is
conscious my mouse is conscious this
mouse not the uh one running around in
the background um everything's conscious
yeah but that's not really what it is
right i mean that is not a full accurate
description of pan psych i i think by
the way it suffers from a from a pr
problem when you hear pansysm you ask
someone at the checkout counter at the
whole foods they're gonna say oh it's
about psychics so i think it gets a bad
rap because of its moniker but um but
it's not really true that everything has
consciousness is that everything as i
understand it participates in in the
conscious observer uh observing or the
process of what we uh deem as
consciousness is that right or is it
true that you know electrons are
conscious
no right yet i think there is yeah i
agree
anika harris who's somewhat sympathetic
to pan psychism among other views you
know thinks something problematic about
the name i kind of think maybe we're
stuck with it now and i mean literally
it does mean
everything mind pan everything psyche
but yeah psyches these days this as i
say the standard view would be
that the fundamental level
has things have consciousness so
for the sake of simplicity you know we
could think about fundamental particles
like electrons and quarks so the view
would be that they have
incredibly simple forms of experience so
we're not talking about you know
the kind of experience a human being has
you know by consciousness to be clear
we're just talking about any kind of
subjective experience our consciousness
is very complicated the result of
millions of years of evolution you know
a horse's consciousness is simpler a
mouse simpler again a bed bug if bed
bugs have consciousness it's going to be
much much simpler for the pan psyches
this keeps going right down to the
fundamental building blocks of mata
which on the panzer's view have
incredibly simple forms of experience to
reflect their incredibly simple nature
and then the thought would be
the ultimate aim of the explanatory
program is to make sense of
those little forms of consciousness
combining together to make
more complicated forms of consciousness
and we thereby ultimately get an
explanation of the
the consciousness of humans and other
animals that we're pre-theoretically
committed to i mean i'm just over seeing
as i'm talking to a physicist i'm
oversimplifying by talking about
particles but there are also you know
field based versions of
uh pancychism and maybe even
conscious wave functions or so um
so often it's put in terms of conscious
particles but that's just sort of the
ease of exposition i think
great um
just chad so it doesn't it doesn't
literally mean every combination of
particles is conscious in its own right
so
so this cup might not have its own
consciousness it's just made up of
little things that are conscious in some
very very simple way
right yeah and again you know just
because something has the name you know
consciousness i mean again physicists
used to be called natural philosophers
you know uh used to have uh physicians
and so forth used to be physicists so
yeah just the name shouldn't be uh you
know construed as a shibboleth or some
some anchor
around the field uh but yeah i agree it
would be great to sort of uh modify it
at some point but we've got so many
questions from the audience uh i i feel
and i hope that we can do a part a part
two someday but i do want to get to a
couple of them just while i have you
here and who knows uh what the future
will bring hopefully it'll bring you to
america at some point and maybe the uk
and we can do this in person but the
first question comes from uh from a
fellow oh well he's a member of the of
great britain at least i think you guys
are still unified in scotland and that's
a man by the name of lee cronin
also guest on lex friedman's show also
past guests on my show
and cronin criticized
uh pansysm today
on twitter by saying pan psychism
appears to not be a real thing it has no
conceptual or philosophical or cultural
meaning it just reflects the
void in our understanding which should
be filled by
more sensible discourse
i'm happy to be wrong but tell me why
and he sends you his his love and
affection by the way
thanks lee that's great yeah i saw that
on twitter this morning i didn't realize
it was it was connected that's great um
yeah so again it's i get i guess it's
um
a couple of things i suppose in some
ways i'm repeating what i've already
said but
part of this is i think you know we we
have in contrast to other cases we have
some grip of the phenomenon of
consciousness before we do the science
so we've got an explanation something
that needs explaining but you could
trust it like with anything else you
know
we usually we don't know what the hell
the thing is before science tells us you
know what is this stuff maybe it's a
fundamental element is the greeks
thought science comes wrong and tells us
it's h2o or um you know when you see
lightning in the skies maybe it's the
anger of the gods science comes along
and tells it's electric discharge but
with like pain i think we already have a
somewhat of a grip on what it
essentially is you know we're talking
about
things that are defined by how they feel
and we know how they feel or defined by
the character of the experience and we
know the character's experience at least
to a rough approximation so that's an
important part why i think this is this
isn't it a very very different to other
scientific cases and then i mean i
suppose
this is just there's no explanation i
mean i think
there are now detailed explanatory
um
pro you know detailed explanatory
claims about how exactly if you could
might want to look at my my paper on my
website how exactly does pan psychism
explain consciousness where i you know
try and lay out a detailed explanation
of how
you know an empirically credible
explanation of how human consciousness
emerges from consciousness at more
fundamental levels and it's going to
work
as i say hand in hand with the
experimental science you know like
another i'm really good psychist head of
hassle merc
spent a year with giulio tanoni spelling
out in her pan psychist terms the
integrated information theory so the two
are going to work together but i you
know i i think there are detailed
explanatory
views here so i suppose i'd want to say
well you know tell me what's
in the details what's going wrong there
maybe maybe what puts people off is
because
as i say because consciousness is not
publicly observable there's always going
to be it's not going to be totally
pinned down by the data you can't look
in a quark and see if it's conscious
just as i can't look in your head and
see if you're conscious
it's always going to be a role for
inference to the best explanation
even once all the data's in
and
talk about but i mean i think it's in a
way it's easy because i think i think
the materialist
doesn't have an explanation it doesn't
have a solution i mean they often admit
that i have a lot of friendly arguments
strong but friendly arguments with the
neuroscientist anil seth who says yeah
look we don't have an explanation to the
heart sushi into the half under
consciousness but his view is
just ignore it and it'll eventually go
away i i
call this ostrich materialism yes
uh so materialism doesn't have an
explanation
psychists have all these now pretty
detailed explanations
what what what's what's not to like and
then you know that's where i think you
get pon psyches and spend a lot of time
sort of just justifying its existence
but what's happening now is people just
getting on with the research program
scientists and philosophers coming
together
uh to see what fruit has yielded from
this and you know that's what's really
exciting i think
amazing
okay well one more last question because
i can't resist uh this is from eugene
bird on my youtube channel dr brian
keating professor goff is fascinating
his ideas about cosmology but his accent
and his manner of dress give him movie
star potential
i would like to know whether or not as
theory and the possible origin of the
universe has shifted or not so if you
could briefly address that i'm actually
not familiar with your theory on the
possible origin of the universe
um i thought i thought he was going to
say but his his accent address is
ridiculous i didn't get i didn't get the
movie
you've got a fan here
now um i don't know what what maybe what
he has in mind that may i mean maybe
i've sort of um
i've had some speculative ideas about
explaining the fine-tuning you know the
surprising discovery that i mean you
know that it seems that for example the
cosmological constant is
i i i
it's
has an unexpected value
and that it's that it's so so very small
but non-zero but it also seems kind of
like a number of concepts in physics
seem kind of just
there's just the right values for life
falls in a narrow range some people
postulate god to explain it some people
postulate the multiverse i used to think
i was probably the multiverse but
actually
it's a big big story but i i i've
actually come to think that the
inference from the philanthropic
reasoning that justifies the move from
fine tuning to multiverse i think is is
a bit fallacious
so so i was messing around deciding well
look if we've already got a conscious
universe
maybe it's sort of fine-tuned itself
maybe we could make sense of some kind
of goal directed activity
uh at the level of fundamental physics
and
we talk about this i'm currently writing
a book where i might sort of explore
this a little bit more so
um yeah i mean
i i feel very silly talking about it and
it you know culturally it seems
preposterous to me but
i don't like the god option i don't like
the multiverse option
that does seem to be this fine-tuning
problem so
maybe maybe a conscious universe that
designed itself is the uh
is the one to go for even though i feel
very silly saying it
well that's lovely and uh appreciate the
compliments there eugene okay we'll have
to come back to part two we've got about
50 other questions phil so if someday
you're willing to come back on i would
be most delighted to host you and answer
the remaining questions and maybe we'll
do a friendly debate with david and
stuart hamra for folks like that but for
now i'm wondering if you are willing to
go and play the game that we call the
thrilling three
[Music]
okay these are my existential questions
designed to elicit uh from my guests the
uh the stuff that matters most in life
which is your wisdom not just your
knowledge i think you've impressed the
universe and my fans especially with
your with your knowledge but let's talk
now about wisdom and start with uh with
the very first one of all which has to
do with uh your departure from this
mortal coil as the bard once said uh and
that has to do with when you depart at
age 120 or later perhaps and you get
uploaded to the great cloud uh perhaps
uh what wisdom
or knowledge would you want to impart in
your so-called ethical will what is in
your ethical will
i think one thing i'd say is
that i've already touched on is never
assume you're at the end of history i
think this is a perennial problem with
humans we always think oh we've got it
all sorted now and something always
comes along
and starts to show cracks you know
consciousness maybe this fine-tuning
stuff and we try to plaster over the
cracks but
always be open to the possibility that
your fundamental assumptions are just
wrong
and you know thinking more kind of
the meaning of life and so on um
i've come to think you know it's hard to
be happy if you approach things saying
what's going to make me happy you know
what do i want out of life
i kind of think you have to find
something bigger than yourself that
you're going to live for you know
whether it's god or socialism or the
advancement of science or curing cancer
or something i think i think
in my experience
real happiness comes from finding
something bigger than yourself that you
can
live for the sake of and i think that's
that's very important
indeed it is uh and the next question
has to do also with the future but not
your immediate future but rather the
future of our species the universe
perhaps
and that has to do with uh sort of the
knowledge or wisdom you would put in or
in on your monolith and you might know
in arthur c clarke's 2001 a space
odyssey featuring a conscious artificial
intelligence by the name of hal i'd love
to get your opinion on how someday uh
but these are monoliths that appear
throughout the show beginning in the
african savannah and progressing to the
moon
and we don't know what they are they
could be time capsules they could be
warnings they could be just whatever uh
giveaways left or you know the the
future equivalent of a cd rom who knows
uh what would you put in it to express
what scientists in your field have
discovered uh that is would be most
impressive to an alien civilization
i think i'm gonna have to say the thing
i'm most passionate about which is that
the reality of consciousness is a
fundamental scientific datum in its own
right
over and above
the data of public observation and
experiments you know i think this is
something we
we we still haven't totally got on board
with as a scientific and philosophical
community
i i believe we i believe we
we will do at some point and i think
it's going to totally revolutionize how
we think about the world how we think
about science and its relation to human
knowledge
so the aliens see that they'll say
all right they've moved on from that
materialist phase they're doing okay
all right fellow the last question
involves the past not the future and
this has to do with what is known as sir
arthur clark's third law which states
the only way of discovering the limits
of the possible is to venture beyond
them into the impossible that's the
origin of the name of this podcast i
want to ask you phil what mysterious
aspect of life might have perplexed you
or given you some concern or trouble as
a 20 year old uh but now makes sense uh
and and give yourself kind of the advice
to your former self uh that would give
you the courage to do as you've done to
go into the impossible
i think i would say to my younger self
the long dark night of the soul doesn't
last forever
i think i've had a lot of you know
i just oh the theory doesn't work you
discover this just doesn't work at all
and you think this is i'm gonna have to
or writing writing my popular book for
the trying to write for a general
audience for the first time and getting
these responses saying this is not a
this is not a popular this is not a book
for a general audience or you know
when i was david chalmers post doc i'd
be i'd work a couple of months on a
theory and he'd come up with an
objection that destroyed the whole paper
and
so you know those things feel
devastating at the time
but often they're you know the things
that are most important for bringing you
to a better place so i like the phrase
um from
uh samuel beckett try again fail again
fail better i think that's yes the other
the other thing that's been an important
realization for me i think is also
true try to get in the mindset of people
you disagree with you know i think at
one stage as a young man i was trying to
win the argument you know oh you're an
idiot yeah but then really getting
curious about
you trying to look out the eyes of the
person you're arguing about why are they
thinking these crazy things you know
trying to get inside their head and
sometimes you can change your mind but
even if you don't i think it inevitably
leads you to a
a deeper understanding of your own view
and so
yeah that's so important to try and
understand the people you disagree with
well
it has been a great pleasure coming to
understand you a little bit more
plug yourself for just a second uh where
do people find you on twitter and your
podcast and elsewhere
yeah i've always argued with people on
twitter uh phillip underscore goth
phillip with one l g goth g o f
f philip gough philosophy.com website i
got lots of things there academic and
otherwise
mind chat my podcast where we interview
scientists and philosophers we had a
great one about free will today with a
a very good philosopher who believes in
free will and um
there's a blog there on my website a
link to
um
my book galileo's error i guess yes of
course wonderful well phil i want to
thank you so much i've been such a
delight and i hope that you'll agree
someday to do a part two and hopefully
you'll be in the chat room when we
actually air this live or
air the recording of it in real time
you'll be in the live chat interacting
and hopefully passing the turing test
absolutely thanks so much i can't
believe i didn't realize at all you
tried to contact me a year ago and i'm
i'm so glad we finally connected up like
it was meant to be it was meant to be my
friend
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
congratulations you made it through all
the way to the end and i hope if you did
that means that you love topics such as
this we're going to have many more in
the coming months you're going to want
to subscribe to the channel and if
you're particularly interested in
concepts such as the brain consciousness
reality i hope you'll click here for the
special playlist that i curated just for
you it has my greatest hits with past
guests like don hoffman david chalmers
uh sir roger penrose and many many
others so make sure to subscribe and
leave a comment below would you like to
see more of these videos about the brain
this three pound super computer that
sits on our shoulders let me know in the
comments below
[Music]